he was a dynamite dynamite dynamite
presence for the pittsburgh steelers
this past weekend and it's been great
watching him he had that acrobatic catch
in week one
steelers fans are falling ahead over
heels in love with him and he's got the
snickers chain for the hungriest player
of the week
he is the pride of abbotsford canada
none other than chase claypool of the
pittsburgh stills fresh office for
touchdown performance how are you chase
i am good guys thank you for having me
on the show thank you for coming
on this show what is life like been for
you the last month sir
uh things have uh changed quite a bit uh
as you can imagine but i'm just trying
to take it all in
and enjoy the fall again and so what
what has changed for you what has been
what has it been like
walk me through it chase claypool i
think just
more um getting recognized more walking
down the streets in pittsburgh
um you know the social media
attention that has began is definitely
uh
been increased tenfold so those are just
two of the main things that i've noticed
well i mean when you're winning the
internet uh chase with some of your
memes that you're putting out there
that's gonna happen uh you know you
with the 7-eleven tweet uh you know ben
and then you and then of course you
uh putting yourself on the head of tom
brady with the four fingers coming up
that that wins the internet chase where
would you come up with that one
yeah so the 7-eleven uh was something
that i was thinking about uh for
for a little bit and i thought it was
pretty clever um and i was kind of
waiting to post it yep
um just went to the right time and then
my friend hank asap went ahead and
showed me that picture
um of tom brady and
he went ahead and made the edit for me
so i just posted that
and i thought it was a great time to do
that as well by the way
on cork and two like that uh on the week
where you score four that that that
works
that absolutely works um your
relationship with ben roethlisberger
walk me through how that has been
helping you so far in 2020 chase
yeah i think um on the field we we have
we've been trying to grow our trust and
within each other in terms of timing on
routes
in terms of knowing the plays in terms
of
if he wants to audible uh if i'm gonna
know what to do
um so i think week by week that's grown
and that's super important for him
uh going into game day to know that he
can trust his receiver and how about
juju
i imagine he he welcomed you with open
arms he's an aces individual
who you know um has had issues with
people who
who were there before him and being
accepted and things of that nature
what's been like with you and juju smith
schuster chase claypool
yeah yeah you uh you hit it right on the
head
he welcomed me with open arms uh for the
very first time when i came there
um you know he was giving me all these
great tips and advice on what to do on
the field and then what to do off the
field as well
to kind of capture that social media um
brand
um so he's been super helpful in that i
can't thank him enough because
you know he's already um i can already
see uh
the rewards kind of coming through so
he's uh he's definitely a big part of um
kind of the social media attention i
feel like
again well in terms of again of what
you've accomplished in the first four
weeks it is
it has been spectacular and that will
gain you some fame um
i'm wondering uh how um you got involved
with football growing up in canada
normally i would ask who's the guy that
you grew up
uh emulating was there a canadian
football player or anyone in the nfl
how about you getting involved with the
sport of football chase
yeah so i grew up a fan of ladainian
tomlinson
um it was a running back and the reason
for that is because i was a running back
growing up
and i wore number 21 going after him
um so i started the age of eight years
old
and i wore 21 throughout basically my
whole career
and uh just something that you know you
play
it's your first love and you um you
can't kind of step away from it so
um definitely an odd path that i had to
go through coming from canada but
uh everything kind of panned out is that
why you chose 11 that you could add up
the
ones it's a two and you got a one on i'm
honestly i'm i'm i'm serious when i ask
you
number 11 how that came by how that
worked for you yeah
yeah so i had a couple of options of
jersey numbers that i could take
um 83 was one of them and that is the
number i wore at notre dame
but uh i thought it was time for a
change um so there's
that couple different elements that
played a part um
one was 11 i felt like 11 made me look
like i ran
faster so that was that was important
and then when i was asked my family what
number i should choose
a lot of my family members said 11 was
their favorite number
um so that was also a big thing and then
you could go ahead and add the eight
plus three equals eleven elements
there well you know jason we didn't meet
at the combine but you know i run at the
combine
uh should i wear number 11 then you're
saying it makes you look
faster i'm looking for anything to help
me look faster why does 11 make you look
faster
chase yeah i think the smaller the digit
um the faster you run in terms of
just maybe even if that's just mental um
i don't know it's hard to explain but i
think that's just something that's like
an unwritten rule
um in football like if i ran the same
speed wearing 89
and then i might not look as fast
as if i was wearing a number 11. so
maybe it's just like
it's just like stripes it makes you look
slimmer maybe that's it
exactly all right that's right so and in
terms of again
notre dame the story goes chase that you
had never heard of notre dame when their
recruiter knocked on your door
in canada is that a true story chase
yeah so i was very unfamiliar with notre
dame
but if i did hear them i wasn't really
correlating
um the college notre dame or whatever so
um when the recruiter did come i was
very very unfamiliar with them
okay does that mean you've never seen
the movie rudy chase is that what that
means
yeah so i didn't see the uh movie rudy
until
i had gotten an offer from them and i
was on a plane ride
to my first visit to notre dame that was
the first time i seen the movie so did
you
it just happened to be on the movie or
you were on the plane or you just
thought you know what if i'm
if i'm going to check out notre dame i
should see the movie rudy
to to kind of get familiar with
everything is that how it worked
yeah so i i went ahead and downloaded
the movie and waved i was on the plane
uh and then i went ahead and watched
that and uh and use some
playing which is crazy so how how real
was the movie chase based on the
experience that you then
had yourself how real is the movie i
think in terms of the environment and
the tradition surrounding our name
uh i think it's pretty spot-on you know
it's a special place to be
and you already kind of captured that uh
pretty well
well you know my guys here are giving me
crap
chase uh because i'm a michigan man i'm
a wolverine
and that movie uh makes me break out in
hives quite frankly you know i'll be
very honest with you
you know but i think yeah you understand
that we just you know these are things
that yeah yeah that
uh that just that's oil and water so uh
congrats on this chain
uh how does it look on you have you have
you posted anything on it yet
for the snickers changed yeah so i
actually uh just
just opened up the box uh probably 20
minutes ago okay
and i am excited to uh get some pictures
in it because it is pretty sweet so uh
it's an honor to
actually have that it's a piece of bling
right i think there's
it's it's quite blingy that that chain
right
yeah so um they actually told me that
this chain has
um like 2300 stones in it
and over 30 carats which is just crazy
to think about
i imagine so so what's next what's your
encore chase
give me an encore for you
for the next like what the season is i
mean when you you're you're four weeks
in and you scored four in a game i mean
you know that's pretty rare last time it
happened was 1979 for a rookie so what's
the encore what do you got for me chase
yeah i think uh the most important part
is just picking up um
kind of where i left off obviously i
might not get four again
um but another big week you guys stack
weeks
and uh you know next week again to brown
uh division rival
is a is a good time to do that well
maybe a sandwich at pramani brothers
that could be next for you
right that you get something might go
ahead and do that right now have you
have you been there have you been there
yet
have you gone i have been there um i
forgot what i got but i just know
i wanted to go back right away i don't
know are they still serving the
roethlisberger there i don't know if
that's the spot
but maybe that's something you could get
uh um they might they might be i've only
went one so i might have to go back and
uh
request that the fries on the sandwich
is next level thinking it really is
chase
it really is trust me well look man
yeah congratulations on it i know you
got a run as i saw you did
um thanks for the the two cents on that
11 is slimming didn't know that
um and congrats on coming out of the
gate like you have it's been a lot of
fun to watch
and um and good luck let's chat down the
line
appreciate that a lot thank you yeah
absolutely take a picture of the chain
and you know
you know uh tag us at rich eisenhower
we'll put it up too
all right sounds good you got it that's
chase claypool everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here